[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
don it is a pleasure to see you and
thanks for making the time to come on
the show i appreciate it thank you for
your very kind invitation it's a
pleasure i've been looking forward to
this conversation for for some time and
i'd like to start with perhaps a name
that my listeners will not recognize and
that is the helmholtz club could you
please
give us some background and explain what
is or what was i don't know the tense on
this
the helmholtz club
the telmos club was a group of
neuroscientists primarily and some
cognitive scientists
like me
that met
roughly once a month
at the university of california at
irvine
but it was neuroscientists from the
whole southern california area from uc
san diego
all the way up to ucla and usc and
caltech
and of course uc irvine and sometimes
from uc riverside
and the the point was for us to get
together
it was sort of led by francis crick and
terry sanowski and vs roma condren
but it was to get neuroscientists
together to discuss
consciousness what was the state
of neuroscience as related to
consciousness
we were trying to problem solve this
this open issue in in cognitive
neuroscience which is what is the
relationship between brain activity and
our conscious experiences and
when i was a graduate student at mit
in the early 80s
it wasn't really
appropriate for graduate students to
talk about consciousness it you know it
was sort of a fringe kind of thing
but
in the early 90s
francis crick basically made the case
that
this problem needed to be addressed
consciousness needed to be addressed and
he felt that he could address it
in pretty much the same fashion that he
had addressed the issue of of life
you know life
had been an open mystery
you could
imagine that there was maybe some elon
vital that was some special
spirit inside living things that wasn't
inside inanimate things but when when
you know when crick and watson
elucidated the structure of dna
the it became obvious that that maybe
you didn't need an elan vital anymore
you could sort of give a reductionist
physicalist
account of many of the basic functions
of life
and and so i think what crick
and
the helmholtz club was really about was
doing the same thing for consciousness
that that crick and watson had done for
life which was to take this thing which
you know
right now seems mysterious
and
get a neuro reductionist
story for it in the same fashion that we
got a
biological a molecular biological
reductionist story for for life and so
so we met and uh it was it was a lot of
fun
i must say it was it was private so we
met in secret basically at the
university club at uc irvine not because
it was clandestine in any bad sense but
because
of francis crick if people knew that
francis was there we would be mobbed and
we wouldn't get anything done and he's
for good reason a very very popular man
and people would want to talk with him
so we met in
in secret and it was invitation only so
each of the members of the club could
invite one or two people to to join in
any given time but it was the the
intention was to keep it really small
there were maybe
15 to 20 of us at most
in a meeting
and we would start we was usually on
tuesdays we would have lunch together
and and then we would go at it all
afternoon we would
we would invite two speakers whose
neuroscience work seemed pretty
interesting even if they weren't
directly working on consciousness we
thought it might be we would bring them
out and grill them and it was it was
it was pretty fun it was intense but you
know it was not at home or anything it
was really just you know a very intense
time
and
we would then adjourn
and have dinner together at some
restaurant usually near south coast
plaza a place near near irvine
and we would go and
close the place out you know 10 11
o'clock we'd be there
talking and
then we'd finally leave so it was a very
intense afternoon and and it was
i must say a real privilege
for
for me i started as a young assistant
professor in the group and i got
i mean i continued all the way through
being a full professor but it was fun
for me to see
how francis thought
he was absolutely brilliant even into
his late 70s and 80s he was like
a complete genius and his understanding
of the field his his command of the
facts his logic was
beyond anything that i ever
could imagine for myself at my prime in
my twenties that was in his late
seventies and he truly
was stunning so it was a great pleasure
and of course the other members of the
terry sanowski
and and
david vanessa and john allman and
yes robert condren the the the list
it was it was truly a fun and engaging
time so i always left inspired and
thinking about consciousness wow
i wish i wish i wish there were a a
current club maybe there is where i
could be a fly on the wall at the very
least
with
such such great and i what i'd like to
do
before we get too far into this
conversation is
define some terms
so
consciousness is a word that people have
heard in many contexts it is a
term or concept that in one form or
another has been of great interest for
thousands of years at a minimum and
you know there are quotes we might
unpack later but quotes i'm fond of that
use this word like max planck the german
physicist right i regard consciousness
as fundamental i regard matters
derivative from consciousness we cannot
get behind consciousness everything that
we talk about everything that we regard
as existing postulates consciousness
could you please give us a
working definition of consciousness
so it's
intuitively
your experiences if you hit your hand
with a thumb with a hammer
the experience of the pain
if you see a blue sky it's the
experience of of the blue in some sense
with words we can only point to it and i
have to
hope that you have your own experiences
that that i can point to in this way
indirectly
but
that's not
so different from what we have to do
with other things so when we when i tell
you you know what is space
well there's really you know what is
what is empty space well
if you don't if you've never seen
and you're not cooperative i can use all
the metaphors i want you're not going to
get it right and if you're blind and i
try to say you know
something about the color red well
you're you're not going to get it and so
so this
in some sense we're not any in any
special problem here with consciousness
that we're not with other things
so
to to be really clear when we take a
child and we
are trying to teach them the name of
something like the word rabbit
right what does the mother do right she
or her father
they sit there and they point
and they point to some furry object
that's sitting there and they say rabbit
and and
the child has to be old enough right a
three month old is not going to get it
but an 18 month old will get it and so
they have to have had their own
experience that their their visual
system has to be
developed well enough and when the
mother points she doesn't go
biped
or quadruped or mammal
she you know she doesn't use those kinds
of terms or she uses like rabbits so she
knows don't use quadruped because you
know you're going to mess up your kid
the first thing you need to say is is
rabbit and so we learn by ostensive
definition that's called a sense of
definition and in some sense we have to
also point
with ostensive definition to what we
mean by consciousness and we have to say
if you hit your thumb with a hammer that
feeling of pain that's part of a
conscious experience when you fall in
love that's a conscious experience
when you're
in a deep sleep
that dreamless sleep that's in some
sense when you don't have this conscious
experience and sort of so we have to use
ostensive definition but but i don't
feel too uncomfortable about that
because we use it all the time and we
don't even know that we're doing it that
way
all right so we're going to certainly
come in and out of the territory well i
suppose we're always in the territory of
consciousness on some level but we'll be
explicitly exploring that from a number
of different angles
like a lot of people i was exposed to
your ted talk do we see reality as it is
and was was struck by
the desktop interface metaphor could you
please
just explain that in brief and then we
can take that in a number of of any
directions
the question is how shall we understand
our perceptions and the relationship to
reality
most of us
just
assume that we know the answer our
perceptions show us reality
not all of it but when i see the moon
there really is a moon and of course i
don't see everything about the moon but
i see what i need to see when i see a
carrot i'm seeing the truth i'm seeing
the the correct shape the correct color
the correct the weight if i pick it up
and of course i'm not seeing this
molecular structure so the things i
don't see but but i'm seeing truly if if
incompletely
and
the interface theory of perception
takes a different tack on on what
perception is it says if we take
evolution of a natural selection
seriously
we can ask a technical question
would
evolution by natural selection shape
sensory systems
to
tell truths about
the physical world around us or whatever
the world might be around us that's the
technical question what is the
probability
that natural selection would shape
sensory systems to report
true
properties of objective reality
and you can show through theorems and
simulations some of my graduate students
working with me on this brian marion
justin mark and uh and and others
and some so my colleagues jayton prakash
when you sing and i've been have worked
on this robert prentner a number of us
have worked on this and
the simulations and the mathematics
all agree the probability is zero that
natural selection
would shape
any sensory system of any organism
to reveal any true properties of
objective reality it is precisely zero
and
one intuition about that is that fitness
payoff functions
we can go into this later on if you want
fitness payoff functions almost surely
have no information about objective
reality they they are not so-called
homomorphisms of structures in objective
reality and so so if we're tuned to
fitness
and the fitness payoffs literally are
not homomorphisms of structures in
reality then there's no way that our
perceptions can be homomorphic to to
reality to
the structures of reality so so what
then if we take evolution of natural
selection seriously and i think we
should
not because
i'm claiming it's the final story
but it's the best story we have
right science
always to its credit
gets new theories
and what we thought was the final theory
120 years ago we now look back on it you
know newton was great but we have much
better theories today and so i have the
same view about all of our scientific
theories that we have today the reason i
take them seriously is not because i
think they're the final word it's just
that we have as human beings no better
theories and so these are so we have to
take our our current theories
seriously and so if we take evolution
for natural selection seriously
of course as scientists we're going to
eventually try to show its limitations
right
but what it says in its current form
is
that the probability is zero that our
senses have shaped us to see the truth
about the world around us so what have
they shaped us to do well the the answer
within evolutionary theory is it's all
about fitness
our sensory systems have shaped us
to
guide adaptive behavior
so we can live long enough to reproduce
basically
and so
one way to put that in a metaphor that's
easier to understand is to say that
natural selection didn't shape us to see
the truth but it shaped us
with sensory systems that are like a
user interface to the truth
so you know right now
we're both sitting in front of
laptops
and
we're able to
i mean i've got
gigabytes of memory and all this
circuitry inside my laptop i have no
idea
about is the truth of that i mean i i
know the words i'm not a you know i'm
not a
engineer of that type so i
so i don't really if i had to toggle
voltages inside my computer to to do
this video with you it wouldn't happen
so if i actually knew the truth and i
had to actually toggle all the bits and
bytes and so forth and voltages in the
computer to make this video happen and
you had to do it
it wouldn't happen we have a very simple
dumbed-down user interface that lets us
control
the complexity of the computer
without
having any expertise in what's really
going on inside and that's what
evolution did for us it gave gave us
simple user interface
that lets us stay alive long enough to
reproduce to interact with reality in
the ways that we need to interact with
it to to stay alive and reproduce
without
having any idea what that reality is you
don't have a need to know so you don't
know and and that's just just the way it
is very few of us know exactly how the
desktop interface on our computer works
and you know when you
drag an icon to the trash can
to delete a file there's a lot of stuff
going on inside there that's involved in
dragging you in in deleting the file
we're blissfully ignorant and that's
what evolution has done it makes us
blissfully ignorant about the nature of
reality
and gives us
icons that allow us to control reality
so to be very very clear space and time
which we typically think of as
fundamental reality
is just the format of our 3d desktop we
have instead of a flat desktop we have a
3d
space-time desktop and objects in 3d are
merely the icons in our desktop they're
they're
not
pointers to objective reality in any
sense there's the colors the shapes the
positions that we see have nothing to do
with true colors and shapes in objective
reality they're just a a nice format
that evolution gave us and that format
is going to vary from species to species
so
as you said the
theories that we have are the sort of
the best stories or
or plausible explanations of of how
things work but those will change
they're constantly in flux and the
theories we had the best theory is 100
years ago 50 years ago 20 years ago two
years ago get replaced and there's this
there's this constant process
of replacement as we update
and and i'm just gonna try to
encapsulate some of what you said and
please correct me feel free to stop me
if i get any of it wrong but that we are
we are optimized through natural
selection for
sexual reproduction there there's
there's no sort of intrinsic
value in accurate representation unless
it contributes to
more effective reproduction
hence the
the discussion of layers of abstraction
and simplification right just like you
would have the desktop and then
many layers below that you would have
assembly language many layers below that
machine code and then you get into the
circuitry and so on
what are some of the implications
of this research because i think for a
lot of people listening
consciousness has been the
domain of philosophers and pontificators
who are operating outside of the
scientific method or
a world where things are falsifiable or
testable right so i would just love to
know
what excites you about this
and what some of the
implications are scientific or otherwise
i would make just one little
change to the summary that you gave and
that is that that
evolutionary theorists probably wouldn't
in general want to say that evolution
optimized us for anything got it
that we typically
there's the term that they use called
satisficing that
you just have to be a little bit better
than the competition right right that's
a good point so that that also then you
know is an interesting thing about it
we're we're not the best at anything
we're just better than the competition
and that's all we need to be right and
and so the idea then that evolution by
natural selection has not shaped us to
see the truth it's just given us a user
interface and that space and time
themselves are not fundamental
they're merely a data structure
that evolution gave us
that
now
whether what i just said is true or not
it depends on you know whether evolution
by natural selection is you know a
fairly accurate theory so i'm just
saying that that's what natural
selection entails
we may get better theories further on
down the line and then we'll have to
revise it but that's what we got
now why is that interesting with respect
to consciousness
well
the reason it's interesting there is
that i would say
my colleagues in cognitive neuroscience
and artificial intelligence who are
interested and in philosophy of mind who
are interested in consciousness
i would say
at least 95 of them are physicalists
that is
at least 95 percent of the efforts in
science in understanding consciousness
assume
that certain objects in space and time
are real
that that they exist whether or not
they're perceived that they have genuine
causal powers in particular
for example neurons and brains
so neurons exist and brains exist
whether or not they're perceived they
have genuine causal powers
and space
most neuroscientists would
would just say of course
space and time are fundamental
physical particles exist when they're
not perceived the brain exists when it's
not perceived
we have to explain how consciousness
could arise from
physical processes that
in themselves are not conscious at least
i guess most physicalists would say
they're not conscious we can talk about
pan psychism and so forth later on yeah
so so this standard
work of most of my good colleagues good
friends who are studying this
are is
we will boot up a theory of
consciousness from a theory of
neuroscience or from a
theory of integrated information more a
little bit more abstract theory
or theory of attention schemas in in
neuroscience and and so forth so but the
idea is that we're going to start with
objects in space and time that we take
to be fundamental reality
and then boot up a theory of
consciousness
and so the first thing
to say then is well
if you take evolution of natural
selection seriously
you should not start there you should
not start with space and time and
objects in space and time
those are not fundamental reality
now
i should also at this point say
you know i'm a cognitive neuroscientist
what in the world do cognitive
neuroscientists know about
physics with it i'm not talking physics
right space and time is not fundamental
surely the physicists will
be happy to put a cognitive
neuroscientist in his place
and let him know that he's out of his
league and and and indeed i'm not a
physicist
but
the physicists themselves independent of
this work on evolution of natural
selection are saying and i quote
space time is doomed
this is nima arkani ahmed
david gross
and and many other
contemporary physicists current
physicists
are you know and i can go into why
they're saying that to me and i can
actually explain it to
a broad audience why physicists are
saying this but basically physics at
least since newton has been
about
what happens in space and time yeah
and now
physicists like neymar connie hamad are
saying space-time is not fundamental
it this is in fact fairly obvious from
recent advances in the study of gravity
and quantum theory that it cannot be
fundamental
and
they're they're spending their careers
looking for the deeper structures that
are beyond space and time
that will give rise to space and time as
as some kind of simple projection of a
much deeper
deeper story so the state of play is
really quite interesting cognitive
neuroscientists studying consciousness
believe in space-time
and objects in space-time is fundamental
when the physicists
are saying
we're spending our careers looking for
what's beyond space time space time is
doomed
so it's really time for
the cognitive neuroscientists who are
studying consciousness
to catch up with what the physicists
have already said space time had a good
run
it was a really wonderful framework and
it's over
and and by the way
reductionism
and space-time
have been spectacularly
successful assumptions of science for
centuries absolutely spectacular hats
off those were wonderful assumptions and
it's uh you know
science really needed those assumptions
but it's the glory of science not to get
stuck
in its current theories it's the glory
of science to know to have theories that
tell you
where they stop
that's that's how you avoid dogmatism
and when evolution of natural selection
says probability is zero that space time
is fundamental
and then the physicists independently
say our theory of gravity tells us that
space time cannot be fundamental
we have our two
pillars of modern science saying the
same thing space time has had a good run
but it's over so the methodology of
methodological reductionism which is
the idea that as
we go to smaller and smaller scales in
space
we find more and more fundamental laws
right so how do we explain temperature
of the air
well if we go to the molecular level we
can
understand that molecules bouncing
around have certain kind of kinetic
energy and the mean molecular kinetic
energy
the microscopic level can explain
what we call the temperature of the air
at a more macroscopic level so
that kind of
of going to
a
reductionist
smaller scale deeper laws has worked in
many ways spectacularly in science but
we now know
that
there is a hard limit to how small you
can go with that approach it's 10 to the
minus 33 centimeters
and
in some sense
that's not very small i could have if
someone said you know it's 10 to the
minus 20 trillion centimeters
i would go oh who cares
10 to the minus 20 trillion that's
tons of zeros but you know
but this is only 33
10 to the minus 33 the the space time
story stops it's not like there's pixels
of space time at 10 to the minus 33
centimeters it's that space time doesn't
make sense
it's
we need a different framework
and in fact as you try and we can go
into it if you want but as you try to
probe space time at you know higher
higher energies and smaller smaller
scales you just start actually engaging
bigger and bigger volumes of space not
smaller
so so gravity
destroys
reductionism
reductionism is is
it worked for a little bit but but
deeply
it's deeply false it's deeply false so
so that's why
this kind of stuff is really interesting
for the theory of consciousness i think
a hundred years from now
when
scientists and historians of science
look back at this period they'll look at
it with some interest
we have
right now clear evidence that space time
is doomed
reductionism is false
we still have this very interesting
sociological phenomenon that 95 i would
say probably 98 99 of my colleagues who
are seriously studying consciousness
are disregarding that and are trying to
give reductionist accounts in which
space time and particles are fundamental
even pan psychism does that we can talk
about it
and
and i think it's going to be
you know
you know century from now when the new
physics is probably well established and
we actually understand these new
structures
deeper than space-time
and we already have great hints there we
can talk about some of the hints i mean
i can talk about them for a broad
audience some of the hints that they
already have from nema or cunningham bed
and others cosmological polytopes
amplitude
there are these structures that have
names and are being deeply studied that
that are much deeper than space-time
that for which space-time arises as in
some sense of trivial projection
and and and in fact when you go to these
deeper
structures you find deep symmetries that
are true of the data that you cannot
even express in space-time space-time
actually becomes a handcuff it it keeps
you from actually doing what you need to
do
so so it's it's going to be interesting
sociologically that
the
the cognitive neuroscientists and
philosophers of mind who were studying
consciousness you know in in 2020
were disregarding what evolution told
them and what physics was telling them
that that's the wrong foundation
now
what is the right foundation
to say that space-time isn't
fundamental
is not to say what is fundamental right
so the best ideas we have right now are
things like the cosmological polytope
and amplitude and sociohedron and so
forth that nema and juan maldosain and
others are working on
so
i then are looking at consciousness in a
different way
i can't in good conscience
attack it from a physical framework
anymore i mean that our best theories
tell us that's not the right way to do
it
but they don't tell us what see the
theories tell us where they stop
but they don't tell us what the next
theory should be
what we have to do
as scientists and this is part of the
fun of science is we have to
be creative
we have to take
a leap into the unknown where we say
what if it was such and such like the
cosmological polito
so we we write down this mathematical
structure
now
then we say okay we have to be able to
test our idea so you have to show a
mapping from whatever it is you start
with like the cosmological polytope
how does it how does space-time arise
from that poly tube
what
what constraints we can only measure
things in space-time right that's where
we can do
our experiments large hadron collider or
neural eeg or fmri we call we do all our
data collection in space time
not because space time is fundamental
but because evolution has forced us to
use an interface and that's what we're
forced to do so we're stuck with this
interface we have to
project everything into our interface so
whatever deeper structure we get
beyond space time we will have to show
how it maps onto the interface that
evolution gave us right so we can
actually do experiments and test it
so
so of course
any proposal
that i make
is almost surely wrong it would be a
miracle if i was right right
in fact i'll i'll go even further than
that i i would i'll say that
science can never have a theory of
everything
why is that
for two different reasons first what is
the theory scientific theory
is an explanation
it says if you grant me these
assumptions
i can explain these other things
if you grant me molecules
and
the idea that they bounce around and
have kinetic energy i can explain
temperature in thermodynamics
but i'm assuming those molecules
okay so the molecules so whatever you
assume is the thing that you're not
explaining there are what i would call
the miracles of the theory now of course
you can then try to say well
uh i i want to i can get rid of those
miracles i can get i can say that
particles
are themselves
what the physicists would call
irreducible unitary representations of
the poincare group which is uh the
symmetries of space time so i can have
my theory of space time and say
particles are merely these
representations of properties of space
time
but now i'm assuming space time
so so every scientific theory is going
to have this thing where it says these
are my assumptions
and those are the miracles and and
that's what a scientific theory is so by
definition the scientific theory can
never be a theory of everything it's a
theory of everything except it's
assumptions the assumptions
are the thing it's not explaining it's
miracles turtles all the way down that's
right just explanations all the way down
and and there's another
deep reason why that has to be true
and it comes from girls in completeness
theorem girdle showed that any finite
axiomatization of mathematics that you
make that's at least rich enough to
account for arithmetic
will have a weird property that there
are truths
that cannot be proven
from that system
and he actually showed that there are
statements that are true but cannot be
proven from within that system if you
add those true statements to your axioms
to your assumptions
so those accents are like the
assumptions of a scientific theory
then
gurdle's theorem still comes back and
says well there'll be new statements
that are true
but not that cannot be proven from
within that new accidentization
and what what this means is that
any conceptual scheme
that we come up with
will always and only barely scratch the
surface of reality
this is a truly humbling
point of view it is to say every scheme
we come up with you can show that you
can actually write down truths
that are true but can't be proven and so
our theories will always
never
get all of the truths and so this is
great job security for mathematicians
and scientists we will always be doing
that
so so that's why i don't believe my own
theory so let me hop in just for a
minute here
and
just to sort of tell a story that leads
to a question and it may or may not be
related to cosmological polytope
or a singular or plural i don't i'm not
actually familiar with that term but
just to perhaps also try to highlight a
few things that you said
again please fact check anything that i
get wrong but
i'm not a physicist nor am i a cognitive
neuroscientist but i am an avid watcher
of documentaries and i was watching a
pbs documentary which was produced and
then made available online pretty
recently called einstein's quantum
riddle and there were a lot of credible
scientists
in this
a lot of scientists and communicators
like sean carroll who has a fantastic
podcast if people haven't seen it
and
towards the end of this discussion
because it tracked the chronology
of newtonian physics which had
incredible explanatory power and utility
for a very long time still does
but then
it traced the the debates between
einstein and niels bohr related to the
implications of quantum mechanics right
and there's a lot of disagreement these
two behemoths
meeting
multiple times a day for for a period of
time
at this gathering of the grades
and
and then ultimately
getting to the point towards the end of
this where they were
gathering experimental data to
test the hypothesis of quantum
entanglement in the canary islands
fascinating documentary i highly
recommend it
and
where it kind of wraps up at the end is
at the institute for advanced study at
princeton
where i did not spend any time uh as a
researcher but i was an undergrad nearby
for a period of time
and i mean the the the halls of of that
place i mean have just had the footsteps
of so many luminaries it's it's
incredible to look at the list
and the
the director at the time uh
robert with two b's he's dutch i cannot
pronounce his last name
towards the end of this
trace out on a blackboard
the
the possibility of a holographic
universe or the universe as we
experience it being a projection of some
type and i think i found on your twitter
you have a great
twitter feed by the way thank you i
found a link to nature
and
i thought a paper i believe is a paper
called simulations backup theory that
universe is a hologram and this is
actually
at this point somewhat uh i don't want
to say dated but it's older 2013.
could you elaborate on
this this holographic model of the
universe this this concept this is the
physicist now this is not cognitive
neuroscience so right but but i i
understand enough to explain it to a
broad audience and that is that
they've they've discovered that
you
think of of
the universe as being a
a hologram
that there is
it is called the ads cft anti-sitter
space conformal field theory duality so
you can have a field theory
without gravity on the boundary
and this turns out to be dual or
equivalent to a theory with gravity of
in the space of one higher dimension
now it turns out this was a major
advance juan malda cena was a key figure
in in doing this but everybody
understands that this is not our space
so we don't live in an anti-descender
space so the the the holographic
principle
works for a space that's not not ours
and
and one problem with the ads cft
holographic problem principle is that
the time on the boundary is the same as
the time in the bigger space in the what
they call the bulk the bigger space
and
that's so you don't get emergent time
you only get emergent space in this so
so the holographic principle as it
currently stands as very very
intriguing and suggestive and it's
making
it's leading
juan maldasena and and neymar connie
hamet and others to try to do the same
thing for our
space time which is a a de sitter space
so we we have a
a different than different thing than
anti-sitter space but but i'll give you
just an idea about this holographic
principle in a
compact sense and where in some sense
the idea first came from
when they studied black holes
and they were trying to figure out you
know when when you stick stuff into
black holes they get bigger
and
and some in some sense as they're
getting more as you put more things more
information into the black hole they get
bigger and so they want to know how much
information could you stick
inside a black hole
what's the what's the amount and you
might think well the amount of
information would look like if i
wanted to stick like hard drives
like i could stick with hard drives it
would depend how much memory i could
store into hard drives depend on the
volume of the hard drives right and you
know so what was the maximum that i
could compress hard drives into a
certain volume to to store information
well when they worked out and this was
stephen hawking who did the math there
was another physicist who first proposed
this but hawking was the one who
actually proved it
the amount of information that you can
stick into a black hole
does not depend on this volume
it depends on the surface area
of the black hole
that's the universe we live in
that you should
really let that sink in yeah that's
squirrely for for me to wrap my head
around it's truly stunning
but if you let that sink in
you begin to understand why space time
is doomed right there there's there's
space time is a great data structure but
it's not the object that we thought it
was it's a data structure
it has certain interesting properties
and so the
the amount of information you can stick
in a black hole depends only on the
surface area of the black hole and and
then it's easy physicists have shown
that that's true of any region of space
any so it's not just black holes they
first discovered it in black holes with
hawking's work but any volume of space
the amount of information you can store
and it has nothing to do with the volume
it has only to do with the surface area
it's so bizarre to think about so that's
the holographic principle and so
really trying to
understand what that what that means but
it does mean that space time is doomed
and we're looking for a deeper a deeper
story let me hop in what i'd love to ask
is no doubt something that a lot of
listeners are wondering and i'm
wondering also
let's say space time is doomed and that
we are as humans operating on this very
high level of abstraction
that serves to
satisfice
our uh
our our drive and our
sort of uh evolutionary imperative to
procreate
as we
realize that
space time is doomed and
that these
these paradigms need to be revised these
theories need to be revised
are there practical ramifications of
this in the same way that perhaps at
some point quantum mechanics were viewed
as
sort of an academic exercise but then
before you know it and it might be
contending with the shut up and compute
kind of
school of thought where let's not worry
about how it works if we can use it to
make something work you're seeing
quantum computing the i think the
implications of which are quite
profound
what what might things look like in the
next 5 10 20 years
as we begin to fundamentally revise how
we think of
reality matter
the interplay of consciousness or the
the role of consciousness is fundamental
what what happens what might manifest
what might change any any thoughts on
that
yes quite a bit
every new advance in science
leads to
unexpected
miraculous
technologies
when maxwell
wrote down
maxwell's equations for electromagnetism
in the mid
19th century
he was
he wrote down these these equations
which sort of captured all of faraday's
experiments with electricity and
magnetism and so forth so verde one done
all these experiments wonderful stuff
maxwell realized that all of the
experiments could be captured in a few
equations
true tour de force
our modern technology
is largely due to maxwell i'm talking to
you today
across country
because of maxwell and the technologies
that of you know
maxwell's equations
stimulated einstein
to come up with special relativity in
part so
i think that the scientific theories
that are being developed right now like
the cosmological polytope and so forth
and and my understanding is that
these guys understand that there's
really hard work ahead right that it may
be
decades before they can this is really
really tough
but
once
we have
a really strong theory that can be
mapped back into space time to make
predictions
here's the kind of technologies that you
could
conceive might come out of that
when we realized that space-time is not
fundamental reality
and we get technologies
based on
structures beyond space-time
if i want to go to alpha centauri i may
not need to spend light years
in a ship i may be able to go outside of
space time
and just get there and not even through
wormholes just through
just understanding the the true nature
of reality beyond space time realizing
that this data structure we can play
with the data structure we can reverse
engineer it i can just put myself there
so
i think
the kinds of things that we take as
fundamental limits on us right now
will will not be fundamental limits so
in other words to to answer your
question you really have to think out of
the box in ways that that
what would happen if space time is no
longer a limit you can just go around
space time so i mean i can go to right
right now for example the physicists
will tell us that
because of the expansion of the universe
most of the galaxies that we can see we
could never get to
right they're they're going way too fast
you can go at the speed of light and
you'll never get there so as fast as we
can go through space time
it's i think 90 or more of the galaxies
are are inaccessible to us too bad all
that real estate is just gone well what
if we don't have to go through space
time suppose we can use
some new structures that the physicists
find that projects into space time but
is far more comprehensive and then we
get technologies built out of that we
just go around yeah we go outside of
space time and pop up where we want so
it's going to be very very different but
that theory is going to perhaps
lead us to a a new realm of far more
interesting than than space time so the
work that i'm doing is a theory of
conscious agents right so i'm proposing
a model in which consciousness is
fundamental and there are innumerable
agents beyond space time
so if that if that model is on you know
and again i would bet against myself i
mean that's that's just a good
scientific attitude to to assume that
you're wrong and try to get a theory
that as quickly as possible will
you know make predictions that you can
test and show you're wrong yeah that's
just the good scientific attitude so
with that in mind i'll just go with this
theory of conscious agents so there are
countless conscious agents interacting
so i get a model of how they
interact i get a model of how the
certain conscious agents we call human
beings use a space-time interface
a data structure of space time to
interact with them
and we use that data structure we have
portals but right now i have a portal
into your consciousness right
it's called your body right
and we're using laptops and technology
to
to take
pixels which are an image of your body
and uh
your voice
and it gets projected to me and i then
understand something about your
consciousness and then you get you get
understand something about my
consciousness and i think that i'm
genuinely
changing your consciousness and you're
genuinely changing things in my
consciousness through the portals that
we call our body so we know that there
are portals in our space-time interface
into consciousness so the question that
comes from from the point of view of
what i'm working on
once we understand the theory of
conscious agents and how space time
arises as an interface that some agents
use can we open up new portals in that
interface
maybe hallucinogenic drugs do that i
don't know maybe they don't but could we
develop new technologies that open up
new portals into the the realm of
conscious agent and if so
are they friendly or hostile and could
they teach us stuff or or you know so
you can see once you start thinking out
of the space-time box
as a scientist you want to let your
imagination go you don't want to be
constrained
you really have to think outside of the
box but then you always have to take
your theory and say okay i need to make
predictions in space and time right that
my colleagues can go and show me wrong
that's that's why this is not dogmatism
and it's not just pie in the sky you
have to think pie in the sky you've got
to think big
to write down your theory you got to
think big but then you also have to say
here's how you can pop my bubble do this
experiment that's how you pop my book so
question about the conscious agents
right i'd love to hear more about how
you
workshop this or simulate or use
computer models
in other words how do you poke and prod
at this
with the understanding that
as you said this is a hypothesis worth
disproving
and you want there to be some predictive
power or
make an attempt at constructing a model
that has predictive power you want it to
be falsifiable right you want to tell
people how they can burst your bubble
exactly how do you explore this
how do you explore
this
struggling for the right word but this
theory of of conscious agents
so there's there's a couple steps
we've we've published a paper
that people can look look up it's called
objects of consciousness so if you just
google objects of consciousness and you
know my name donald hoffman
it's free online and you can just see a
paper where we propose a simple model of
consciousness using
simple mathematics probability theory
has things called markovian kernels
and my attitude about it is i'm trying
to start off with a very very simple
model what our 1.0 model
right the the simplest math that i could
do that sort of models the idea that
conscious agents
have experiences they make decisions and
they act to change the experiences of
other conscious agents that's the basic
idea
mathematically now you you get a
dynamical system
that's called a markovian dynamical
system
and so so now we can start to study
these markovian dynamical systems of
conscious agents and
look at how
their
behavior
would predict properties of
consciousness
and how they might predict
the emergence of space-time
so one thing that i've been working on
i was working on this very very heavily
a little over a year ago and then covet
took me down for about a year so i've
been
i was out of commission for a year with
with covet a long haul code it took out
my heart oh i'm sorry to hear that
yeah it um
it made my heart
almost fail so it's taken me a year to
get back on my feet so so i'm planning
to get back to what i was doing before
kova took me out but
the the idea
that
i was pursuing is that
the long-term behavior
of these conscious agents the so-called
asymptotic
behavior
has
structures that are very interestingly
related to
structures that nema kanihamed is
finding beyond space-time
so i would like to show
that
the asymptotic behavior of this
conscious agent dynamics
has a fit with some of the structures
like the amplitude
cosmological polytope that they're
finding behind space-time
but if that were right then the
structures that they're finding behind
space-time
would would still be simplifications of
the conscious agent dynamic because they
would only capture the asymptotic the
long-term behavior not the full dynamics
of the consciousness so once again it
would so we'd have the full dynamics of
consciousness a certain projection of
that would lead to
the cosmological polytope and the
amplitude and a projection of those
leads to space-time
so the idea would be to start with the
theory of conscious agents
through the asymptotics project to the
cosmological polytope project to space
time and that way we would get
consciousness
leading to predictions in space time
that we that we could test
so so that's that's
a big project and i you know i'm glad to
put it out there so that someone who's
much smarter than me can go ahead and
run ahead of me and beat me to it so i
would just be delighted to read about it
from someone who could beat me to it
on that so we're going to come back to
cosmological polytope because i feel
like
after the 17th time it comes up we
should probably return to it and cover
it however i want to ask you something
first
and i'm going to wade into this maybe in
a in a roundabout way and
we'll see where it goes might be a dead
end might not be but if if we're talking
about
from understanding correctly
the fundamental
the possible fundamental error of taking
a bottom-up approach to understanding
consciousness
that is sort of starting with the
neurological structures and
using our space-time tools to kind of
build from the smallest
upward to sort of explain the
phenomenology and the subjective
experience that people have that they
label consciousness
how would you answer the question
is consciousness
localized
and i ask that understanding there's a
lot of controversy around this and
people will
look at different types of injuries and
either use it as proof for or against
the idea that consciousness is locally
generated so to speak by what we you
know the three pounds of goo that we
hold between our ears
but there are people who take the
opposite stance and and even though i
think it's very difficult to test might
look at the brain as a almost a receiver
of sorts how do you
think about this and i apologize if it's
a sloppy question it's a great question
if you wouldn't mind unpacking that
however it it seems
seems best i'd love to hear your
thoughts
the receiver theory so a lot of people
might think that i'm proposing a
receiver theory that the brain is a
receiver for consciousness and i'm
absolutely not
because that theory would is assuming
that the brain exists and is a real
object with real causal powers
and that somehow there's the brain and
there's consciousness and somehow
consciousness interacts with the brain
as a receiver
and
that's absolutely not what i'm saying
nothing inside space and time has any
causal powers
nothing
everything inside space and time are
merely perceptions within consciousness
from the from this framework so the
brain
is
an icon in my desktop
that appears when i look inside skulls
and as soon as i look away i delete that
icon and there is no brain so
to be very very clear right now i have
no brain
there is no brain if you looked inside
my skull of course you would see a brain
but but that's an icon that you create
on the fly the icon exists when you
create it and it you delete it when you
don't need it so neurons do not exist
when they're not perceived
nor does space time
so that's that that's my point of view
right so again i could be wrong but but
i just want to make very very clear it's
not the brain receiver because that's
giving the brain too much
existence
right the brains only exist when they're
perceived just to stand in for the
audience so people might be squirming a
little bit in their seat here
of course so if you say that nothing in
space time
can uh if i'm getting this right act as
a causal agent that's not to say that if
someone holds a gun to your head and
pulls the trigger that's not going to
splatter your brains all over the wall
behind you but rather that that is
an abstraction
sort of on the
user interface that we are using i mean
there can still be
consequences experientially
so is the question then just a
it's based on false assumptions because
it predicates that the brain is actually
something that exists and persists
whether or not we're looking inside your
skull
so that's that is the big assumption
that the brain that physical objects
exist
and have causal powers even when they're
not perceived and by the way the
physicists have tested this so there's
two very technical terms for this one is
local realism
and the other is non-contextual realism
so local realism is the claim that
physical objects like electrons
have
properties
like position momentum and so forth
real values of those properties that
exist
um whether or not they're perceived and
that have influences that propagate no
faster than the speed of light
so so the realism is to claim that they
have their properties even if they're
not perceived
and the locality the local is that they
influence no faster than the speed of
light so together it's called local
and most of us might think that of
course local realism is true it turns
out local realism is false it's been
tested and local realism is dead this is
simply untrue
and that's the end of the story local
realism is false non-contextual realism
is the claim that again realism the
property particles for example are their
properties like position and momentum
and spin when they're not observed
and that the values of those properties
do not depend on how we measure them
that's the the non-contextuality
and non-contextual realism is false
so so local realism is false
non-contextual realism is false
i conclude that particles
themselves
don't exist when they're not perceived
they have no property they have no
position they're not there
they think if you have no position
you're not there so so they're not there
in spacetime itself
is not there spacetime itself
is merely a data structure and particles
by the way you know when we say that
physicists say that they're irreducible
representations of the poincare group
they're basically saying that the
structure of space time the
representations of the structure of
spacetime is what particles are
there
they fall from the structure of our of
our interface
i think a better framework is to think
about this is as
a data compressing error correcting code
that we're using
if you think about space time and
particles as as part of a data structure
for data compression and error
correcting code as part of our sensory
interface
i think it'll be a much more useful
framework so
so
that's that's sort of why i go that way
now but maybe i should stop and let you
okay
so i may take us into
deep water here with with my next
question but
i will ask you because i know that your
next commitment today
relates to the the subject of
of death so in a few hours you have a
commitment
that not a funeral but rather an event
that is discussing various topics and
questions surrounding death how do you
think of death
given
all that we're talking about and
sort of the first order second order
third order implications of all of that
how do you think about death
so physicalism has a very clear
implication for death
if space-time is fundamental
and
elementary particles like electrons and
quarks and protons and so forth are the
fundamental nature of reality and what
you are
what your body is is just an assemblage
a complex assemblage of particles
and your consciousness
is somehow an emergent property
of
certain activities of those particles
say brain activity
then it's very very clear that
that
in death when the brain dissolves your
consciousness dissolves and that's the
end of the story that's that's the end
that's it
that's a very very clear implication of
physicalism
we can talk about pan psychism
but but the physicalism you know strict
physicalism that's that's the end of the
story
if consciousness is fundamental and
space-time is just an interface
and our bodies are merely icons that we
use to represent
certain assembly interactions of
conscious agents and we can go into how
i think about that
then
on that approach
there is the possibility
that some aspect of
my consciousness
survives death
now
there i have to look at you know the
mathematics of the model and and
go into it but
it may be for example that
the bear awareness
that's associated with me just awareness
without content that that survives
but
all the
details of donald hoffman and his life
story within this interface maybe that
all dissolves maybe
we can
that's a story about what is
consciousness up to we can talk about
what is you know if consciousness is
fundamental what is it doing and why
what what what what is the dynamics of
consciousness about
and we we really to answer the question
about death we might have to answer that
question too
it's a big one
please continue
[Laughter]
so i'll try a stab at that question
because i think it relates to the death
question
so what is consciousness doing and why
you know the the right answer is i don't
know and i've only seen one idea
that seems deep enough to at least be
worth
thinking about i'm not saying it's the
right idea but the only one idea that
seems deep enough to at least be a
candidate and it again comes from
girdles and completeness theorem
girdle says that
essentially
no matter how much you explore within a
particular conceptual system
there's
you can't get all the truth you there's
there's always going to be more to
explore
mathematically
so if consciousness is the fundamental
nature of reality and consciousness is
all there is then mathematical structure
is only about the possibilities of
consciousness
that's all that there is to be about
and so
what if
what consciousness is doing since the
exploration of mathematical structure is
in principle
unending
then
perhaps the exploration of the
possibilities of consciousness itself is
in principle unending
and therefore
consciousness
what is up to is
exploring all of his potentialities
and the reason is continuing to do that
from our perspective is continue to do
that is because there's no end to it in
principle
so consciousness itself is in some sense
always learning about itself
and so
perhaps then
what we are
what you what people are and what cats
are and what dogs are and what amoebas
are and so forth is consciousness
trying on different headsets
different realities
and exploring
and
and losing itself i mean so this very
interesting idea that the consciousness
chooses to really explore so deeply that
it loses itself in the exploration
doesn't even know what it is
it becomes a physicalist
it actually thinks that consciousness
isn't fundamental it goes through the
whole bit and then slowly has to wake up
and and so doing it really explores what
it's not
and what it is in some sense to know
what you are you have to know what
you're not
and so
so on that point of view
the hoffman icon
is simply
consciousness
exp taking a perspective on itself
looking at itself through a particular
space-time headset
taking a little projection and from that
headset i there's a finite there was a
birth there was
growing strong until your 20s and 30s
and then after your 40s you start
declining and you know in your 80s and
90s you die
and
that whole process is just
consciousness exploring itself from a
particular perspective in which case
maybe
the hoffman
icon and maybe a lot of stuff can be
left behind but in some sense
consciousness itself
has
has learned something through that
experience and the 8 billion other
people and the
quadrillions of amoebas and the who
knows how many viruses and and so forth
consciousness is just trying on
innumerable headsets and when it's done
with that headset it takes it off
and
awareness is
is perfectly fine
the the raw awareness is fine but the
the the detailed icons that happened to
appear space time icons objects in space
and time brains neurons all those things
those were you know those are just
those were just icons and you know
you studied them and then you realized
pretty cool really you know mount
everest what a beautiful icon
death valley what a beautiful icon these
are really but i'm not that i'm
something even more transcendent than
space and time i'm more transcendent
than death valley and so so
consciousness is just waking up i mean
again i'm trying to tell a story i'm not
saying that it's it's correct but it's
just it's the only story i've seen so
far that at least is deep enough that is
worth taking
seriously
who is the origin of this
this story and can you ever know that
it's accurate do you think through
testing our experimentation
the story that i'm saying right now has
an interesting
way that you might be able to test it so
this dynamics of conscious agents that i
mentioned is a markovian dynamics right
you can make it so-called stationary
dynamics in which the entropy of the
dynamics doesn't change
but you can show that even if you have
this markovian dynamics of consciousness
in which the entropy never changes
any
projection
by by conditional probability any
projection
looking at that dynamics
we'll see it as
increasing in entropy
in other words
the arrow of entropy the arrow of time
is an artifact
of the projection
so consciousness itself has no arrow of
time
but you can prove from this mathematics
that you get an arrow of time by
projection the proof is trivial it's
like two or three lines so here's a
project that i think would be really fun
can we show that when you look at all
the different ways that you could
project consciousness in this
mathematics the conditions under which
all these different arrows of time the
entropy that you get
satisfy
the lorentz transformations in other
words can we get special relativity out
of this we would have to model also the
space aspects of it what's happening to
space
as you know projection of the dynamics
of of these conscious agents but we see
the time aspect so could we actually
show how special relativity arises as
just different perspectives that
consciousness can take
can take on
a fundamental dynamics of consciousness
that's that's that has no arrow of time
that's the kind of thing where we could
start to make brand new predictions that
could be testable
and i just want to as a sidebar
say to folks that
i know we're
probably serving quite a bit up on the
plate to chew on in this conversation
and i would highly recommend folks who
are like good lord i mean how do i even
wrap my head around one tenth of this
to
consider
exploring some of the
documentation of
for instance
quantum entanglement which does get i
think misappropriated and used by a lot
of kind of hand wavy new agey folks but
if you just look at the experimental
data and double slit experiment and then
the kind of later generations of of
experimental data like what was done in
the canary islands
i think they were using two quasars
which is just like
who funds that i want to know it's
incredible that somebody actually put
the money up for that pretty awesome
if you start to even dip your toes into
that or watch a few presentations by
carlo rivelli who is as i understand it
i mean a skilled practitioner and
physicist i think he focuses on quantum
gravity he's brilliant yeah brilliant
guy so he's not just a stage presenter
with a decorative title this guy
actually does serious work
you'll you'll begin to see just how
weird
some of this gets
when you start to push around the edges
let's chat for a second because it's a
term that has come up
pan psychism could you please explain
what this is
so there are various versions of pan
psychism but the the basic idea
is that if you take elementary particles
like electrons and protons and so forth
in addition to their physical properties
you know we have position momentum and
spin and so forth
and psychosis they also have an
elementary unit of consciousness
and
when you take an electron and a proton
and put them together to form a hydrogen
atom
then
somehow the consciousness of the
electron the consciousness of the proton
together somehow combined to create the
new consciousness of the hydrogen atom
and when the hydrogen
two hydrogens get together and an oxygen
get together
and combine to form water molecule
then
the consciousnesses of the hydrogens and
oxygens somehow combine to create the
consciousness associated with the water
molecule and then by the time you get up
to humans you have so many
of these particles coming together that
you know human consciousness
emerges somehow so it's it takes
physicalism too seriously
from my point of view
right it's saying that these electrons
exist
they really do exist in space and time
so these things are are fundamental
fundamental reality and in addition they
have this other fundamental unit of
consciousness
right so is it one analogy that's
sometimes given is that
you know particles had position
and
momentum
and
but in in newtonian theory but with
quantum you discovered that that wasn't
enough you needed something called spin
so they just added spin so particles now
have spin right and and and so the same
thing we could do the same thing with
conscious we had a position momentum
spin we now have to just add this other
unit of consciousness they have a unit
of consciousness we'll do the same thing
we did with spin sort of sort of the
idea and so i
my my approach i call conscious realism
where i say consciousness is fundamental
reality and space time is merely
one user interface out of countless that
consciousness can use
right there's countless interfaces space
time is just one
pan psychism at least the version that
i'm talking about here and i think is is
the standard sort of the standard one
is i think smuggling in
the idea that space time and particles
are still somehow fundamental reality
philip gough i think we could have a
good discussion about it i think that
that's what what he says i would love to
have him disagree with me who is if
philip goff
philip gough he's a a very famous pan
psychist hand cyclist now just because i
i i think it'd be certainly
satisfying for me to to know this just
based on my curiosity are there what you
would consider
credible scientists who
ascribe to pan psychism or is it
relegated to kind of other arenas
well i think that the integrated
information theory that christophe coog
and
julia tanoni are studying
it's often taken as a pan psychist
theory it says that certain physical
systems also have unit of consciousness
if they have the certain property called
integrated information the right kind of
integrated information then they also
have you know a certain amount of
consciousness is quantified the amount
is quantified by the degree of fee with
the integrated information so that's a
sort of a pan cyclist thing because
they're taking again space time and
particles as a as a reality right as an
objective reality but that reality if it
has certain kinds of properties also has
consciousness so it's it's in that sense
of pan cyclist kind of approach so yeah
tanoni and christopher are of course
brilliant brilliant scientists i mean
the fact that i disagree is irrelevant
these these are geniuses
so
i did a bit of reading on this prior to
this conversation pansysm and
having lived in japan it struck me how
the sort of output of
these assumptions and these models is
actually very similar to
in some respects not all but animist
religions like shintoism right the rock
the moss the dirt everything has sort of
a a consciousness of one type
or another just a a quick sidebar not to
say they're related nor that all
panseikists are shintoist i agree with
that that raises a question that i i
would like to just mention briefly
please and that is i'm saying that
the question of which
objects are conscious and which are not
yeah
or the question of which things are
alive and which things are not
the answers that we give right now
are an artifact right
of our interface
if reality is not space and time and
physical objects
our interface is then giving us more or
less information about some realm beyond
space and time beyond our interface
right
now
when i see a cat i think it's alive
i see a mouse i think it's alive when i
see amoeba yeah
a virus i don't know i see electron i
say no definitely not alive well
is that a genuine insight into the
nature of reality or am i mistaking a
limitation of my interface right or an
insight into reality
and and so this is the kind of question
that arises when you no longer take
space and time as fundamental it opens
up the possibility that we've actually
got the question of life and the
question of consciousness so
fundamentally wrong that we're asking it
the wrong way
the question could an electron be alive
or not is the wrong question
it's
in fact my body is not alive
my body is merely an icon it's not alive
in fact if you close your eyes my body
disappears if i close my eyes my body
just this is merely an icon so the the
only question is which icons on our
desktop give us effective portals into
life or consciousness
and ones that do not doesn't mean that
we're not interacting with life or
consciousness it just means that our
interface is giving up of course it had
to give up reality is too complicated so
once again this actually shows how
important it is if space time is just an
interface we better get on with the
program and not fool around with space
time being fundamental we're just asking
we get life wrong we the question of
what's living and and not living is in
fact the wrong question
so this is what how important it is if
space time is not fundamental we need to
change your science how we're doing our
science yeah it's going to be uh quite a
copernican upset
it's gonna make people very very unhappy
for a long time i expect let's segue to
cosmological polytope which if i ever go
back to burning man i feel like that
should be my nickname on the playa
cosmological polytope what is
the cosmological
polytope
well or the amplitude hydron i think i'm
getting that correct the amplitude and
so forth and social heater
what i'll talk about is at a high level
what what these guys are are up to and
what they're finding yes please so
they're looking for structures beyond
space time
that can give rise to space time
and they want to do it in a way that
they can test empirically
the the tests that they have are of two
fundamental kinds one is the
scattering
studies that they do at the large hadron
collider where you take subatomic
particles at high energies smash them
into each other and see what sprays out
what they do is they they look at the
so-called scattering amplitude if you
have like two gluons hitting each other
and four gluons go spraying out what is
the amplitude of the probability for the
various kinds of ways that that can
happen and it turns out those the
scattering probabilities for these
various
events
is the fundamental data that needs to be
explained
so those are the big big data
and
when
several decades ago when they were
starting to try to build the
superconducting supercollider in the
united states which didn't happen but
they they realized they were going to be
doing so many of these collisions per
second then most of them would be things
that that weren't interesting so you
needed to be have some way of
analyzing the data very very quickly and
getting rid of the stuff that was not
interesting so you can find the the
needle in the haystack that was
interesting so they needed to compute
these scattering processes
the so-called scattering amplitudes and
it turned out but if you got
you know like two gluons in and three
going out it was you know a lot of
algebra and before going out is like
hundreds of pages of algebra
for one one computation for one
amplitude
it was nasty just like
so they were doing it using quantum
field theory and feynman's
approach to things and the the
experimentalist said to the theorists
look
we can't do hundreds of pages
of algebra
billions of times a second
well you supercomputers can't do this we
you you've got to simplify the math for
us and so some some mathematical
physicists said okay we got to help out
our experimentalist friends so let's see
so they they found that they
a miracle they could collapse all this
stuff down to a couple pages and then
another miracle they collapsed it down
to two or three terms they couldn't
believe it they thought this must be a
one-off so they but over the decades
they discovered one after another all
these scattering amplitudes that were
going into hundreds of pages of algebra
could be collapsed to three or four
terms that you could write down by hand
and so that's what the the amplitude and
the the cosmological polytube they're
actually showing that there's this
deeper
reality there are deeper symmetries so
the what they discovered there are
deeper symmetries that are true of the
scattering data that cannot be seen in
space-time
so when you let go of space-time and go
to these deep like the amplitude and
cosmological you you are now dealing
with deeper symmetries than space-time
that are true of the data and all of a
sudden the math becomes trivial
if you do it in space-time because
you've got the wrong framework you're
doing it you're doing it in this
projection space that's not not right
it's not the right it's not the deepest
reality when you go to the deeper
reality you see the deeper symmetries
and the math becomes trivial so that's
what they're they're the kind of thing
that makes them think they're on to
something here we're seeing new
symmetries the computations become
much much easier and now we're seeing
these structures now they don't know
what the structures are about
so so the this is really an interesting
point in the history of physics
so these geniuses are
ours are
like we're trying to go beyond space
time
what the heck is beyond space time how
do we how do we go there what what kind
of flashlights can you use
now you're speaking my language right so
that's the the problem that the you know
hats off to these guys like
neymar connie hamid and juan muldesana
and these these guys they're they're
they're brilliant and they're brave
they're they're going so what they're
doing is they're saying
we have to of course really know all the
physics in space time and they know it
backwards and forwards they know all the
scattering so if they know all the
symmetries
they're going now we're discovering that
there are these symmetries in the data
that can't be explained in space time we
need to go to these deeper structures
so you have to
take a leap you have to
propose these structures like the
cosmological you have to propose them
right
and then propose how they map back into
space time and show
that you can make predictions that are
testable now the other thing they're
looking at is not just the scattering
data from the large hadron collider and
other other
you know colliders
but also they're looking
at
the correlations you see between um
stars and various objects in space
the two and three-point correlations and
so forth the the idea is that they might
think of the whole universe as one big
scattering event from the big bang
and they might be able to get data that
you couldn't get their energies high
enough in in this you know the colliders
that we could build on earth but there
was much bigger energies of the big bang
and so we might be able to probe nature
more deeply by looking at the sky at the
macro and looking at these correlations
in the sky wow
just so i can take a note for myself who
are the researchers
or the the in what is the institute that
if people want to do a
deeper dive on this they should look up
in this case well you'll like this nema
arkhani hamed is at the institute for
advanced study at princeton oh look at
that
that makes sense it makes sense
as i think juan muldacena
as well yeah one is so a lot of work is
being done there but but
nima's influence is huge he's trained a
large group of
young people who are working on this if
people are interested in it i highly
recommend nima arkhani hamid
gave
a semester-long class at harvard
in the fall of 2019. so if you just
google
nema or connie hamad harvard lectures
2019 you can you can get everything that
i've been talking about in all the
detail he's got amazing 20 more lectures
on this that's incredible okay so we
will put this for everybody listening
we'll put those in the show notes since
if if you like me are not quite clear
how to spell this person's name we will
we will get it
and we'll find the link so we'll put it
in the show notes at tim.blog podcast i
i'd love to
return to something you mentioned in
passing
which is hallucinogenic drugs so
you you may or may not know i've been
very involved with
funding scientific studies over the last
i don't know what the exact range is six
to eight years within the realm of
psychotropic drugs with a focus on
psychedelic compounds
across a whole
spectrum of say classes so tryptomines
phenethylamines but also including some
stranger ones like salvon or an a
just derived from uh salvia norm
this is an area of deep interest to me
and
i would love to know what you find
interesting about hallucinogenic drugs
or what
questions they raise
anything at all that
leads you to find them
just in an area
of of interest
i should first say that
i'm interested but i haven't actually
explored myself you know not that i
won't but but i haven't yet
but i i have many friends who have
and some who've who've really done it
systematically
like with five meodmt some who have been
very very systematic about it and others
who've taken psilocybin and and so forth
and
the
the reports that they have are very
interesting in many cases they do find
themselves interacting with other agents
yeah
other conscious agents and some of those
agents are
you know
teaching them and some of them are rough
they're rough teachers and and and so
forth
and
from a physicalist framework
you have to conclude that this is just
brain malfunction right this is not an
insight into reality
this this is is the brain
being kicked in ways that it wasn't
intended to be kicked with
neurotransmitters at levels or
concentrations that are not supposed to
be there and that's that's the whole
story and the same thing happens at
death with near-death experiences those
those are merely brain malfunctions
effectively
but in in ethereum which consciousness
is fundamental
it still may be the case that these are
merely hallucinations and no insights
right this is absolutely possible
but it also i i cannot with my theory of
conscious agents i cannot dismiss the
possibility that perhaps
the drugs are somehow opening up new
portals into this realm of conscious
agents new access new that we didn't
have before to a different interface
that's right or through a different
aspect of our interface that you know
that hadn't opened up before
so
from my point of view then what i really
need to have is a theory of portals
how
space time
i have a portal right the portal is your
body and i'm interacting with your
consciousness and we have one technology
we have one technology by which we know
how to open up new portals
one really important technology it's
very low tech but it's having kids
when you have a kid
you open up a new portal into
consciousness so
we we do
know that there is a way to open up new
portals into could you elaborate on that
just a little bit what do you mean by
that so you and your significant other
mm-hmm
decide to have a kid well right
and you have no idea
whether it's you know who that person is
going to be like right so you have a kid
you start off as a sperm and an egg and
nine months later through
um a magical process of morphogenesis
yeah
which we don't understand but by the way
mike levin at tufts
is is doing some beautiful work on
morphogenesis and showing that it's not
just the molecular biology that's
involved it there's bioelectric fields
electric fields that are actually
guiding the body growth the body
morphology and the morphogenesis is
truly stunning so there may be
a lot a lot there but but by the time
the child is born
you now have this little portal you have
very little insight into the conscience
you know if
it's happy or sad
right it cries or or not but but over a
period of years you see the portal
getting more and more sophisticated
you're getting deeper and deeper insight
into
the conscious agent that you're
interacting with
and and so
studying that and studying the
morphogenesis process we may be able to
come up with new technologies that allow
us to open new portals into the realm
of conscious agents and who knows that
technology may look like
silicon and circuits who knows if so we
you know it might look like artificial
intelligences that
are conscious but it would be very very
different from the standard
approach to this right standard approach
of people thinking about this is that if
i get
my
artificial robot complex enough with the
right kind of complexity maybe the first
flickerings of consciousness will emerge
from the pattern of activity in the
hardware somehow and if i get it really
sophisticated they'll be more conscious
so somehow
the physics of the ai is fundamental but
if the physics of the ai has the right
dynamics then consciousness might emerge
i'm saying something entirely different
physics is not fundamental space time is
not fundamental consciousness is
what we call physical objects are merely
the ways that we play with our interface
to open new portals into the realm of
conscious agents
and so once we understand
you know maybe it's the amplitude the
sociohedron the cosmological what's
behind space time and maybe conscious
agents behind that if we're lucky
then and we understand how the interface
is related to it we then be able to
build technologies that open new holes
new portals in our space-time interface
and
then one once we've done that once we've
figured that that out
then we'll have lunch
then then we might be able to answer
your question which is
are
these
drugs
really opening up new portals now we
have a theory of portals yeah do the
drugs really open up new portals or are
they just screwing up the interface
right this is just pathological firing
right or is there more to it so we have
a little work to do yeah we do have a
lot of work to do
and
you know i
i just want to share a few things that
may be of interest so the the first is
that
with many of these compounds i mean
there are people who i consider i'm not
going to name them by name because a lot
of them are under the radar at the
moment but
intelligent thoughtful
rational to the extent that any human is
rational rational actors
who are very interested in trying to
get a deeper understanding of at least
experiment with these entity encounters
which
in the example that's in my mind
surface
very
consistently with
dmt or nndmt which is
very different subjectively in its
experience than five meodmt five methoxy
dmt
and so they've looked at me at means of
extending the interactions
by changing say the mode of
administration to intravenous and so on
there it it at the very least the
questions are very interesting and i
recognize for a lot of people listening
this is going to sound like we're going
well i'm not going to use we that's the
royal it's unfair to you don that i'm
just going to uh crazy town but
just
allow me to be kind of self-indulgent
for a second if you if you also look at
the sort of ethno-botanical and
ethnographical studies
and just self-reporting in the histories
of tribes say in south america who use
ayahuasca as just one example
the
it is it is
largely accepted among the cultures down
there and you know it hinges on certain
cosmological views and so on but
that shared visions are common so that
people in
close proximity
taking these drugs at the same time
often have shared visions they see the
same thing
slash experience the same thing
so i i am and and
it's easy i think to or
on one hand just dismiss all of this as
kind of the the ravings and
made-up stories of people who have have
taken
drugs that have kicked their brain as
you put it in ways that the brain is not
intended to be kicked
but the you know these things have also
been used
and i don't think the people in these
tribes are stupid by any stretch of the
imagination but
and
furthermore i'd say you know the
pharmacopoeia and their knowledge of
medicine often outstrips
what we consider modern medicine like
for a long time curare which came from
the amazon and played a huge role in the
creation of anesthesia as we know it
today
in hospitals
was studied in
in many different capacities and there
were certain ingredients that were
included in these mixtures such as black
pepper or various species of pepper that
were thought to be inert and the
conclusion of the the western chemistry
doing the analysis was you know
these uh these tribesmen have no idea
what they're talking about yeah they got
one or two things right but this has no
bearing and that may be true in very uh
very many instances but it turned out
that you know bioperine if i'm
pronouncing that correctly in these
pepper species increased bioavailability
so it increased the speed of onset of
these paralytics
and
i'm going to stop in a second but but
this is an area of deep interest if if
you look at how
let's just say ayahuasca has been used
historically it's also been used for
hunting and warfare
so it's just it and i'm not and i'm not
saying any of this holds water but at
the very least
you know consistent use by humans over
millennia would seem to imply some
utility
and if one is to believe the claimed
utility
it it raises questions that we are
currently not able to answer
from a a
physicalist paradigm anyway
end of end of speech
i agree and i think that this is very
much worth exploring i i think that i
cannot dismiss and should not dismiss
the possibility that these these drugs
are opening up portals into this this
other realm i mean it's also possible
that they're not yeah we need to have a
a mathematically precise theory of what
we think
you know this realm beyond space time is
and what what portals are but i i don't
dismiss this at all there's
a brilliant researcher named monica
gagliano
who has spent time with these native
societies and and that they're
using these
these plants
she's
and
she's got a book called thus spoke the
plant
i love the title by monica gagliano and
she was
inspired by these
tribes and their their work to do new
experiments on plants that showed that
that that plants
have
capabilities that we never thought they
can do classical conditions she's done
classical conditioning on plants plants
can learn to associate a sound with food
and they will grow their roots
to just the sound that's been paired
with the food when there's no food there
so you can do classical conditioning
with plants
and
she's got other
remarkable discoveries about plants and
so
she she says there's a a wonderful movie
that just came out called aware
where she and christoph and and and
several other people are are interviewed
i highly recommend the movies called
aware i forgot the subtitles something
like explorations of consciousness or
something like that for the subtitle but
the the movie is called aware it just
came out
very recently so monica is in that
kristoff is in that and she they they go
through and talk about her experiences
with the tribes that you see are sitting
with the tribes then you see the
experiments that she's done so i think
that there's
again i don't know what the answer will
be here because until we have the
science
you know a mathematically precise
science we just don't know
it could just be screwing up the brain
in you know in some sense or it could be
a genuine insight so
there's a lot of hard work ahead yeah to
to to do this tbd but you're if you're a
physicalist we know the answer you're
just screwing up your brain yeah you're
just completely kooka bananas and should
be
put in a padded room
so you can't damage yourself which you
know in fairness some of these things
you do have to be careful with this uh
this book looks fascinating thus spoke
the plant yeah monica gagliano
253 ratings it's like 4.5 4.8
and i should also recommend
you know in conjunction with this or
if people wanted a place to start that
is a little shorter there's a there's a
piece called the intelligent plant that
michael pollan wrote for the new yorker
at one point which also speaks to this
in so much as plants can sense gravity
the presence of water feel an
obstruction in the way of their roots
before coming in contact with them
there's time lapse
videography or photography of plants
finding poles to climb up
in using means that are very unclear
really really fascinating piece that's a
bit older 2013 so i would imagine that
monica's book has has more up-to-date
science that's right this will give food
for thought to vegetarians
yeah that's true the ethical
considerations right if plants are this
intelligent you mean are they sentient
yeah right
from my point of view of course
that's the wrong question right the
question of which things are conscious
which or living and which is the wrong
question we're always interacting with
consciousness when you see something
that's called a plan you're interacting
with consciousness yeah it's just that
your symbol is what you call a plant but
you're really interacting with
consciousness that's a that's a thorny
dilemma for people to sort out i'm gonna
save that
for the for the bioethicists and develop
a better better understanding i'd love
to ask you about a book which was gifted
to me
i did not agree with everything in it
but i did find
some of the explanations and thought
exercises to be
so worthy of exploration uh very simple
but are you familiar with the book
called biocentrism
have you ever heard of this yes what is
your what if what is your opinion of
this book i think generally it's it's
it's okay i i think that
he he's letting go of the physicalist
framework which is
like i agree with letting go of the the
physical framework the word the
disagreements come
so i agree with him that physicalism is
is an inadequate framework so absolutely
so i agree with him on that
so the the disagreements may or may not
come
in what we propose is beyond space time
right right so i particular model of
conscious agents that is mathematical
and he may or may not like that i mean
you know he he may disagree
in his case he he doesn't have any
specific mathematical models so it's
more
you know
just using the current evidence to
suggest that
physicalism
is false
that that something
more lifelike more conscious like may be
fundamental
but but it doesn't go to the the next
scientific step which is
okay give me a mathematical model that's
falsifiable or testable thank you for
answering that
you mentioned a number of names
nema something something ahmed which i
will get right in the show notes
which scientists
they don't have to be scientists but i i
do like playing within the realm of
falsifiable hypotheses
if proven true that have predictive
predictive
powers
any anyone you would suggest or taking a
look at or who you find
interesting
in terms of what they are attempting to
figure out or or testing
one person i i find
brilliant and interesting is chris fuchs
fuchs
he's a physicist
and one of the founders of cubism qbism
oh yeah formerly called quantum basinism
but i think he dropped that and just now
calls it cubism cubism is catchier
cubism is catchier and
and he had some technical reasons for
maybe dropping the quantum bayesian name
yeah but he and and also david merman is
another rudiger shock they're they're
all quantum cubists
and it's it's an interpretation of
quantum theory
that
is
very very close to what i'm saying
they make the point that
each act of observation
in physics
is an act of fact creation
when you measure the position of the
electron
you're not measuring a pre-existing fact
you're creating
the fact in the act of measurement so
that's that's the cubist
approach and of course i i find that
very very cordial to to what i'm saying
that that that space time is just an
interface and these properties are are
things that we create when we look
they're data structures you create when
you look and then you garbage collect
you destroy it when you don't need it
and so particles are things that we
create when we need them and and in in
his he's got a paper called
cubism the the the
the
outer fringes of content basinism it's a
2010 paper i can give you the exact
title of it but in that paper chris
fuchs actually describes an experiment a
mathematical experiment that some other
mathematical physicists did in which
they prove
they show using quantum theory
a series of ex of measurements that you
can make
where you can predict with probability
one
what the outcome will be
but you can prove
that
that quantum mechanics is incompatible
with the value being there before you
measure it i think i'll need you to say
that one more time
so this isn't chris fuke's paper but
it's some other work
a series of ex of measurements that you
make where you can prove
that with probability one what the
outcome is going to be
but you can also prove
that
the outcome did not exist
the the the value did not exist before
you made the measurement you can prove
it right so that's again against the
local realism but it's also against what
einstein said so now einstein was a
realist right
who said if you can without
interfering in any way with the system
predict with probability one
what the outcome of measurement will be
then there's an element of reality
corresponding to the thing that you
could measure with you know get with
probability one
so that was einstein's
so with if without disturbing a system
you can predict with probability one
what the measurement will be then
there's an element of reality
corresponding to that measured value
that's what einstein said very really
nice idea and what chris fuchs in his
paper shows is
einstein was wrong here's something
probability one we know what the outcome
is going to be and we can prove it
didn't exist
so this is once again
the
the nail in the coffin of space time and
particles being fundamental reality they
don't even
exist when they're not perceived when
they're not measured so it so cubism
says every physical measurement
is an act of fact creation you create it
in the act of observation yeah
and that that agrees with what i'm
finding from evolution by natural
selection you create the symbols you
need on the fly
to survive long enough to reproduce
so cubism for folks we'll put this in
the show notes as well and we'll get the
title of that paper is
q-b-i-s-m that's right not to be
confused with cube bit although i do
recommend for people interested that you
maybe listen to my conversation with
steve jerbetson who's very involved with
d-wave and other quantum computing
companies which will also
really stretch the boundaries of
the mind just to consider
what is involved and these are things
that are happening right now i mean
these are you know google and many of
these companies have vast resources
dedicated to quantum computing it is of
great practical value but it gets into
some very very strange
territory
i'd love to know what experiments you
know if you could wave a magic wand or
if you just had a pet billionaire who
would fund whatever you thought was
worth funding what type of experiments
would you like to see or do any
experiments come to mind that you would
like to see
you would love to see done
in the next five ten years
the magic wand i would say that the the
stuff i'm working on
we need
to just be funded for the next 10 years
to really get the mathematics
worked out of this third conscious age
but in terms of experiments that could
be done right now my take would be i
would
go to nima arkani hamad
at
here's all the money you want what what
experiments do you want to do because
you're the one who's actually telling us
how to go beyond space time what do we
need to do to go beyond space time and
really understand the structures behind
there so he's he's got some ideas and
and in fact he was
in fact
rap still is
sort of the lead on a new collider that
was going to be built in china i don't
know what's happening on that so i would
say some of the most beneficial
experiments we could do right now are
the ones that really help us push beyond
our current space-time
understanding and really go into
the structures that we are beyond spaced
on that's going to be our our our our
best bet i mean the kinds of stuff that
that i would do i think as a
neuroscientist and so forth or
they're they're incremental but his
stuff would be transformational
on my part i think we have to just go
after the mathematical modeling and then
try to tie it into the structures that
they're finding i think that's the the
best way for science to
to move forward in the in the quickest
way on this
i'm going to ask a totally unrelated
question thank you for that and i did
finally i found i'll just i'll just read
it for folks so nima or kanihamed
n-i-m-a
next word a-r-k-a-n-i
hyphen h-a-m-e-d american canadian
physicist
i will be looking brilliant into this
gentleman also seems to have done a hell
of i mean i guess i keep the the older i
get the more i'll view other people as
young
[Music]
but
he's done a lot he's 49 i mean he's he's
really he's gotten a lot done wow very
impressive he's stunningly brilliant and
hard-working
what are you reading
these days or what do you have on deck
could be something that you've finished
reading something you're working on
currently something that you're looking
forward to digging into i'm just curious
what
what your information diet looks like
these days
well so
several different fronts
one is on the very technical fronts i'm
i'm studying
some information theory in this the
entropy conditional entropy and so forth
trying to
and then you know the poincare group
and irreducible representation of the
poincare group to see if i can't show
how space-time
emerges from these conditional
probability projections of the dynamics
of consciousness so the idea is that
consciousness has this dynamics that has
no arrow of time there's no change in
entropy
anytime you look at that dynamics from a
perspective by using conditional
probability
you get an arrow of entropy but
different ways of looking at it will
give you different entropic rates so the
rates will change depending on how you
how you condition
i would like to show that i could get
the a group of transformations of the
these entropies
that then give me back um the poincare
group for example that would be
again it wouldn't prove i'm right but at
least prove
that
we have a theory that's compatible with
what we know that can actually map into
space time it would actually be
tremendous so i'm looking at technical
stuff on markov chains information
theory and of course the related physics
on this i'm also in a completely
different direction because i feel like
when we're studying consciousness on its
own terms
there's very few of us
as scientists
who are are trying to study
consciousness on its own term so i'm not
trying to think of consciousness as some
you know how does
neural activity give rise to
consciousness and so forth i'm asking
what is consciousness qua consciousness
i want a scientific theory of
consciousness that doesn't assume
a physical world is the foundation at
all sounds very difficult it absolutely
is you have to just like reboot
everything without all the props that
we've had of space and time so what do
you want in the mathematical model of
consciousness now
i i as i mentioned i published that
paper um objects of consciousness
a few years ago
and people can can read what we have
there
but
i realize that
i should listen to
various spiritual traditions
but now spiritual traditions are a mixed
bag
right yes
i have no doubt that many practitioners
have had deep insights
and that i have no doubt that many of
the things that they say are dogmatic
nonsense
and the question is how to separate
the two right
part of it is that they they may have
had insights but without the scientific
technique
of writing down mathematically precise
theories and then testing them
you you just can't make progress even if
your insights are are deep and correct
you can't take them and evolve them very
far if you're just using words you have
to use mathematics and then make
testable predictions and so
i've read the bible
and it's a mixed bag
so i'd get some insights from that
i
had a chance to talk with the dalai lama
and give a talk to him and get some
interaction with with him i'm reading
eckhart tolle
and uh rupert spyra who is rupert
sparrow spyra s-p-i-r-a rupert spyro who
is that i just i don't recognize he's a
spiritual teacher from england
and i've run across him i had a chance
to have breakfast with him
up in san jose there's a science and
non-duality conference that i've gone to
many times it's called science and
non-duality meets once a year until sort
of you know it got messed up with covet
but
it'll probably restart
and there you know they bring together
scientists and and people from spiritual
traditions to have a dialogue which i
found
very very very very useful and so so
again my attitude is
as a scientist
i don't think any of our current
scientific theories are correct
including my own i think a century from
now we'll all look back and look at our
current theories like we look at
newton's theory it was great for its
time but it was time to move on and i
think all of scientific areas will be
the same way so i i have the same
attitude about even the spiritual
teachers and the way they think about
what they've experienced on the other
hand i think it's important for me as a
scientist to listen very carefully to
what these spiritual teachers
are are doing they seem to have explored
in ways that perhaps i and other
scientists have not
and can i get insights so i i'm spending
time reading you know eckhart tolle's
books and rupert spira and and
just
again
taking everything with a grain of salt
but but i don't want to just ignore this
i want to really think about it deeply
as i try to get a mathematical model
yeah i wonder if you know as you're
talking about this i wonder just
thinking about the convergence of
spiritual practice not just
the
saturation of religion but let's just
say
practices and mathematics
and i mean just offhand and this could
be completely misguided i'm wondering
if
there have been any
pairings of mathematicians and spiritual
practitioners in say india i mean
there's such a
strong uh certainly millennia
long set of traditions related to
deep practices of various types but also
mathematics i mean you have an
incredible i don't say tradition but you
do have a historical record of of
outstanding mathematicians out of out of
india as well
i know two of them
all right
and
i am very very lucky to count them among
my longtime collaborators so chaitan
prakash and manish singh
these guys are mathematical geniuses
and with also deep
spiritual understanding they have their
own spiritual purposes and chaitan has
worked with me for over 30 years and
manish for almost 30. manish was a
student of mine but he's now
my superior
he's uh he's he's absolutely brilliant
so these any mathematical savvy in our
papers is not due to me it's due to them
and perhaps any spiritual savvy is also
due to them so i don't know what i do
but anyway these guys are right and also
um i was very fortunate to work with a
gentleman named now he wasn't
indian
he was jewish um bruce bennett
and he he was just
a flat out genius mathematician with
with also deep spiritual
understanding of eastern spiritual
traditions i think informed his stuff so
so i've been around i've been fortunate
to be in to collaborate with these
brilliant mathematicians
and so i agree absolutely
i'd love to just know as you're reading
from these religious and spiritual texts
whether it's scripture like the bible
or
any other source
how do you
pull from that what is your kind of
filtering mechanism could you give any
examples right because i think that
there are
there are people who can
hold
the let's just call it kind of
rationalist
mathematical faculties while
simultaneously having
faith-based
religion or spiritual practices they
don't have to be faith-based i mean you
could be a mystic
with direct experience
it's very
it's very different though to integrate
those things you can you can have those
two things coexist in you but some would
view them as antithetical to one another
right so how do you how do you filter
and are there any examples that come to
mind of things you've pulled from
spiritual practices and
look to port over into the scientific
a couple things
one
from the upanishads there's this saying
not that which the eye sees
but that whereby the eye can see
know that alone to be brahma the eternal
and not what people here adore
not that which the ear hears
but that whereby the ear can hear
know that alone to be brahma the eternal
not what people not that which the mind
thinks
but that whereby the mind can think
know that to be
so there's this distinction between
pure awareness
versus the contents of awareness
right
and
when i
realized that they were making that
distinction i look back at my math and i
realized that when i was writing down
these
mathematical models of consciousness
they're probabilistic models and you
have to write down when you do that you
have to write down a probability space
so there's just this thing it's this
timeless thing
a probability space
and then you have the dynamics occurring
on that space
so the mathematics itself also models
there's this
pure awareness beyond time
beyond the dynamics
that's the problem what i call the
probability space
and then there is the dynamical system
of the contents that appear and
disappear within that system so i
realized that that
there is this
really interesting
correspondence between the kinds of
things that they're saying
the contents there's pure awareness and
in some sense they'll they'll say what
you are is not any of your contents
you're not your body you're not you're
the sound of your voice you're not your
possessions
none of that stuff is you you are the
pure awareness and the pure awareness is
what survives death but not necessarily
any content
well that that does seem to
correspond pretty well with some of the
mathematics that i wrote down just
because i had to write it down that way
that's just what you do when you write
down the mathematics and so so i find
these kind of correspondence is really
interesting and i want to pursue them
further the other one that i think is
really interesting is the insistence and
i get this
you get this in many of the spiritual
traditions but but
i see it really clearly like when
eckhart tolle is explaining these things
in his books like a new earth and uh the
power of now and so forth
he points out that
thinking
is not a very deep intelligence compared
to
the the realm of our reality beyond
thought
so in these spiritual traditions one of
the things you do in meditation is you
let go of thought
completely right
any thoughts that come up you
don't fight them but you don't
give them any engagement space
the illegal let them go and and the the
point that they make is
that as you do that and it may take you
years to really
be able to do that
you are getting in touch with
an infinite intelligence
that is much much deeper than any
thought intelligence and in fact is the
source of all intelligence that comes
through our thoughts and so so if that's
right that that also makes sense from
from
this girdles and completeness theorem
point of view that i've been taking on
this that is that consciousness
there's no description of it including
any conceptual thought description that
we can give that even scratches the
surface of the depths that girdles
incompleteness theorem says is there so
so i see this correspondence again
between
letting go of thought so there's this
really interesting thing we need thought
without words we wouldn't have this this
conversation right hard to podcast very
difficult hard to podcast with so so
it's not like words are bad and concepts
are bad
the question is how what is the
relationship between conceptual systems
and this intelligence that transcends
any conceptual system that's the really
interesting now the spiritual traditions
will say it's a pointer relationship
where i'm using the word aware as a
pointer of course the word aware don't
take it too seriously you can also call
it consciousness whatever but don't take
the point or too seriously and then some
pointers are really bad right so we have
this notion of good and bad pointers
well so as a scientist i'm going now
that's really interesting
what is what do we mean mathematically
by a good pointer versus a bad pointer
can we actually
take these ideas and make them more
rigorous so for example i'll just give a
really
simple concrete idea of kind of thing
that i'm talking about
the real numbers the real line you know
from minus infinity to infinity right so
that's a lot of numbers how about the
integers i'm the mathematician but it
sounds like a lot of numbers it's a lot
of numbers right
and now just now just the integers from
minus infinity to infinity well
right
there's between zero and one there's a
whole bunch of real numbers right so
there's there's a sense in which the
integers aren't a very good
approximation to the real numbers right
there's so many real numbers between 0
and 1 0 is not really telling me
anything about the integers between 0
and 1. so so
you could say that the integers are a
pointer to the real numbers
but it's a really bad pointer but now
take the rational numbers
a rational number is an integer divided
by an integer so you just take any two
integers you get a ratio those are
called the rational numbers and and it
turns out that the rational numbers are
what or what mathematicians call dents
in the real numbers you can approximate
a real number
as close as you want with rational
numbers
but not with integers
now it turns out there's just as many
rational numbers as there are integers
this sounds crazy i just so the number
of integers equals the number of
rational numbers
the integers are a bad pointer to the
real numbers but the rational numbers
are a good pointer to the real numbers
yeah they can approximate them so this
is the kind of thing that i see
can we take the spiritual idea that
what we are
is an infinite intelligence that cannot
be captured by any
finite conceptual system language for
example
speech thought
we have this notion of good
bad and worst pointers
can we
make this idea which has been for
thousands of years in the spiritual
traditions can we now you know dust it
off and and and make it serviceable in a
more rigorous way can we actually take
spirituality
and turn it into a scientific discipline
again which is not to desiccate it and
deprive it of of its life but to make it
precise and make it actually
serviceable actually make predictions
i would love
i mean my father was a minister in a
protestant fundamentalist church here's
what i would love to the sermon the guy
gets up and his sermon is guess what we
just discovered mathematically about
spirituality this week you won't believe
it here's here's this new theorem about
spirituality
uh sign me up i would love to go to a
church like that where they're telling
you the new discoveries you know where
rigorous discoveries about good pointers
to you know here's here's how to think
about consciousness here's a better way
to do your meditation and we now have
this mathematics to explain why you
should do it this way and not that way i
would just love that kind of thing and i
think that science and spirituality
eventually could collaborate
now question for you would would
spirituality
not at that point cease to be a useful
term in so much as
if if spirituality is and
please feel free to disagree with the
wording but
an attempt to describe
with
words these
clumsy imprecise labels
glimpses somehow if we if we look at the
mystic traditions mystical traditions
into this
fabric beyond
space time
like by the time they converge we will
have the the tools and the mathematics
to obviate the need for this word
spirituality is that nonsense that i'm
that i'm spouting well i think i think
that's a very natural question and and
my attitude is that
science itself is in the same boat
science will never have a theory of
everything and science will always as as
newton put it
newton described near the end of his
life he described himself as
a little boy on the seashore
amusing himself with a little shell or a
pebble
when the vast ocean of truth lay
unexplored all before him
i think that's exactly right
and that's the right attitude that
science should have is that no matter
how far we
we
get with our scientific theories we have
to understand that we will always be
playing with pebbles on the seashore
just like newton was at least newton
was smart enough to understand that
that he was
playing with pebbles and so the fact
that the spiritual people are also just
playing with pebbles on the seashore but
they're pointing to the ocean beyond and
saying it's it's beyond conception
that's why i think the notion of the
pointers is really important yeah for
sure
good pointers versus bad pointers we we
can never get a theory
of that
but if the spiritual traditions are
right and if conscious realism is right
even though you can't get a theory of it
you can know it by being it
right so you you you can't
know
that infinite intelligence through your
conceptual analysis you can get good
pointers to it and science can help us
get good pointers
but you can only
deeply know it by actually letting go of
thought and being it
but then
as a scientist
you can go there and be it
and then come back
with the goods
in your own conceptual system and make
progress in your science and that's what
i that's where i see this possibly going
scientists would actually learn once we
let go of our physicalism
would learn actually how that we we as
scientists are that infinite
intelligence
but our conceptual tools
are inadequate so we have to go into
that infinite intelligence in pure
silence
and then learn how to come back and take
our whatever insights we have gotten
into
terms that we can actually write down to
mathematics and we go back and forth
that way so that's where i see science
and spirituality eventually going
and this so it's going to require a
scientist to actually be not only a
master of mathematics and the theories
but also a master of letting go of
thought and actually going into the deep
intelligence if this whole approach is
correct
how much pushback slash blowback
criticism have you had to deal with from
the scientific community for bringing
this the s word spirituality into the
fold of conversation have you
experienced that or have you not really
run into it
my colleagues have treated me very well
i think
as a scientist i absolutely not only
expect but request
hard-nosed pushback that's i mean
i'll be the first to say that my theory
of conscious agents is probably wrong so
and i should just just to
confirm that before we started recording
you're like the more you push back the
better like right love it hard hard
questions
that's my job is to contend with that so
just wanted to confirm that so plea
please continue that's right so i'm not
interested in my own dogmatism at all i
i i would like to be disabused of my own
mistakes as quickly as possible
so so
my
and when my colleagues
what i usually talk with them about is
not so much the spiritual side of things
but more evolution of natural selection
entails that physicalism is false and we
have to get over that hump before we
even get anywhere near spirituality so
that's where i've really pushed with my
colleagues and and i'm getting good
feedback and good pushback of the kind
that i would hope so there's a team at
yale for example
that you mean
are trying to defend realism they're
trying to use evolution by natural
selection
they're looking at the simulations we've
done and the mathematics we've done
they're trying to find
conditions in which systems could evolve
to see the truth if they were the truth
and so we're having a very profitable
back and in forth on that and
my own attitude is that
it's no surprise that you can find
certain conditions
in evolutionary theory in which under
those special conditions yeah
organisms could see the truth the the
thing will be that they they are
probability zero so if you are going to
bet
you know you would not bet on them
so and that's a whole other discussion
i'll just say one thing about it and it
has to do with
their approach is if you have lots and
lots of fitness payoff functions
and you force the
organism to only
see the world as a unified hole
you can't carve it up
then in that special condition with with
many thousands of payoff functions
they're coming very very quickly
you you don't get you can't adapt to any
payoff function and so truth is what you
sort of default to
but what we're what we've shown so
that's that's great
thank you i'm grateful to them for for
doing that
what we've shown is that if you allow
an organism
to cluster the payoff functions into
similar payoff functions so that you can
sort of take these 50 payoff functions
are roughly the same so we will just
make one's payoff function for all of
them for all the various now a quick
question fitness payoff function i mean
i think of
i'm probably very simplistic of doing
payoff fitness payoff function as
successful reproduction what would other
payoff functions be well so so
ultimately if i'm not totally
misunderstanding it right so you know
you understand correctly
evolutionary theory has been turned into
mathematics called evolutionary game
theory
in an evolutionary game theory what you
do is you set up a game where players
have different strategies
and when one strategy interacts with
another strategy it will get a payoff
you know a a dollar amount or something
that it gets for that so for each
strategy interacting with another
strategy you have what you get a matrix
of these payoffs that you that you get
for strategy and directing oh i see you
have rules for accruing points
effectively that's right the more points
you get if you get more points than the
competition then you have greater chance
of reproducing effectively than the
competition got it so you have these
payoff functions so when you mathematize
evolution by natural selection you get
these payoff functions
and
yes if you
if you allow
an organism now that's dealing with
thousands of payoffs and we do we have
thousands of payoffs that we have to
deal with but if you can group them
cluster them into these
these actions with these payoffs
have roughly the same payoff so let me
make what i call an object out of them
so what we call
visual objects or physical objects are
merely data structures
by which we sort of
put together a bunch of payoff functions
together that that
so that we can just use that as a
shorthand for if i if i have an apple
you can bite it
you can eat it
i i wouldn't do other things with it you
know i wouldn't try to drink it
right i wouldn't try to mate with it so
there are certain payoffs you're not
going to get from an apple you know and
if with a stick right i mean i can beat
someone with it but i wouldn't want to
eat it and i wouldn't try to drink it so
different objects will have different
payoffs and so so what we what we've
showed in our simulations just in the
last couple weeks so this is just brand
new so this is in in response to the
team at yale we found that yeah what
they did was correct but as soon as you
let
organisms cluster the payoff functions
into objects
then
then you get far more payoff for not
seeing the truth and you make these
false you make these fake objects which
are just data structures for the fitness
payoffs and so once again we actually
then see where objects come from they
they come not as representations of the
truth but as mere conveniences for
representing payoffs
don this has been tremendously
fascinating uh we i i could certainly
continue with many questions from many
hours perhaps another time perhaps
around two yes is there anything else
you'd like to say anything else you
would like to mention
before we bring this first conversation
to a close
i think the thing i would highlight
we've talked about it before but i would
highlight it at the very end
and that is the nature of science
that
good scientists understand that we will
never have a theory of everything
when they talk about a theory of
everything it's with a wink and a nod
that that we will always have the
science is a never-ending process of
getting deeper and deeper theories but
each theory
always makes assumptions
and as as scientists
it's not our duty to believe our
theories it's our duty to
study the theories
really understand them thoroughly
and then try to break them
the point is to break your theories when
you can break your theory
when you find its limits that's when you
break out the champagne because that's
when you're going to go to the next step
and girdle's incompleteness theorem
tells us that this process will never
end
so there is job security go to science
josh
i love that
well
done people can find you on twitter at
donald d hoffman you you have a
fantastic twitter feed you you really
share quite a bit in terms of references
and articles and so on that's donald d
hoffman h-o-f-f-m-a-n
and it has been
so much fun to have you on and to have
this conversation i appreciate you
taking the time
it was a great pleasure tim thank you so
much and for everybody listening we will
add copious and detailed
links in the show notes as per usual at
tim.blog
podcast and until next time thank you
for tuning in
you